the raiders with
another home game this week this time
against the atlanta falcons the team's
expected to be
pretty unpredictable come sunday ron
futrell takes a look at the betting odds
this week
okay so now we're deep in the second
half of the nfl season right now we'll
talk about the raiders falcons in just a
moment
but this is a good opportunity to talk
about who's going to be
in the super bowl the oddsmakers and the
bettors here in vegas
are making their picks saints right now
they've got the number one seed day
eight and two record
they're six to one and the asc is a
little bit uh
more uh top heavy there you got the
chiefs obviously the favorite at three
to one and the steelers being undefeated
they're five and a half to one the
raiders are long shots at 50-1 to make
the super bowl now after that loss
that last minute loss to the chiefs last
sunday
they are in atlanta for week 12. the
falcons are unpredictable but dangerous
we opened the game three still at three
we have taken a 200 000
bet on the raiders minus that three uh
tough game though you never know what uh
uh falcon team was going to show up uh
you know some weeks are good some wicks
are bad
so the raiders play their next two games
on the road they get the falcons this
sunday then they play at new york
against the jets
oh and then they come home here to las
vegas to take on the indianapolis colts
that'll be a big game
with tremendous playoff implications for
both teams
ron futuro reporting eight sports now